Hyper compilation for such we had named
the process of altering the neuro DNA
and changing a human being into an
eternal hyper dimensional being we spoke
of it as the birth of an idea in a sense
whose literalness is not easy to convey
to minds that have not brushed with
schizophrenia
we hope that mind driven by will - the
good could enter into the process of
generation and guide it toward the
production of the imagination modulated
resurrection body so dear will writing
and modern UFO enthusiasts the dead
we believe that hyper compilation was to
be the shamanic defeat of death that
those doorways the dead enter through
daily were finally to be thrown open to
a hypercar belated humanity that would
then have freedom of movement to and
from an eternity in which the species
was a living reality the presence of our
dead mother or Carl young Newton and
Bruno Pythagoras and Heraclitus was an
overwhelming and all-inclusive intuition
that was shared and could not ignore
there seemed to be an ideological
lineage whose task was the shattering of
the historical continuum to the
generation of the living lattice of
hypercar belated humanity all these
visionary thinkers had worked on their
part of this project
now as the secret worked of human
history the generation of Adam's cosmic
body lost since paradise neared
completion these shades stirred and
press near to our Amazonian campsite as
we became the human atoms critical to
the inception of the transformation of
man into a galaxy roving Bodhisattva the
culmination and
testing of the highest aspirations of
spawning star coveting humanity we
wonder why why us to such questions the
mushrooms spoke in my mind without
hesitation because you have diligently
sought the good and because you trusted
no human being more than yourself the
emotional impact of these sorts of
exchanges with intense beyond anything I
have ever experienced
I felt humbly grateful to the point of
Tears
I felt exalted we wanted to salvage
paradise for Humanity and we thanked all
gods and make sure that our eccentric
quest out of all the lives and paths
being lived on the earth was placed by
fate to be so near the cutting edge
where the outer shamanism had failed we
would succeed the rescue of the timeless
pearl of human immortality from the well
of death would through the act of
hypercar Galatian become a living
reality for every person who had ever
lived all the pain and suffering and war
and desperation would somehow be
replayed and made right through the
intercession of the mystery of higher
dimensions and backward flowing time the
wave of understanding that had been
gaining that the 27th of January was now
about to crest the wave was so strong
and to be nearly visible in everything
around us the lenticular shape of the
approaching lattice seemed to be
everywhere that I looked
you